Let's get back on the phones. A lot of people
hoping to talk to me at six one, seven, eight
three zero 47,
one 50. Let's go next to, where do we want
to go? There's still a lot of interesting
phone numbers here. Why don't we go to the
two, two, four area code? Who's calling today
from two to four?
Hello, David.
Yes. Who's this?
Hey Steve. I'm actually in West Virginia.
The area code is a Chicago, but oversee and
my mom and my long time, uh, the, your first,
I'm actually calling in. I'm just wondering,
just as a, uh, a lead up to this, have you
seen this video that circulating social media
right now? Uh, what, what would they, they
call themselves patriots, but they showed
up at an, an article communist type of book
fair and had masks on kind of antithesis style
and were basically they're trying eat in the
day. Yeah. Um, the leftist now, I don't know.
Do you think that fantasize, I didn't need
it to match. Susan, are people going to start
trawling as they're going to be civil or not
civil wars extreme but is going to start getting
violent between uh, the radical right and
the radical left in your opinion.
Listen and Tika is so small for t for to meet
its match. Yeah. Antifa is so small that for
Antifa to meet its match, it would be like
just like 20 dudes. I mean I don't even, I
don't even know. It's just [inaudible] my,
my view on this is that there are all sorts
of different actors in the political space
that are willing to commit physical acts of
violence to try to make political points or
achieve political goals. The vast majority
are on the right pointing, you know what the,
what about Antifa stuff I find to basically
big picture be a distraction. No serious leftists
that I know are advocating for, you know,
violence against people and I, I feel like
the entire thing is just a massive distraction.
I haven't heard about this particular thing
you're talking about these people that are
fake rightists maybe or, I don't know.
They'll see it. I promise. You'll probably
see it since you watch political stuff all
the time that's on Facebook. But yeah, it's
all, it's all very interesting. I don't know,
I'm just, uh, times are tough and I just don't
want, I agree that no one should be resorting
to violence and, you know, peaceful. I, I
just wish that the right could unite against
the common enemy. I think because of the u
s government, then the insurance companies
and
yeah, I don't want to let the government is
the enemy. I think the government, the government
has been co opted by corporations. I'm not
saying, you know, saying the government is,
the enemy is a little bit too like an Arco
Libertarian, small barrel and extremist thing,
but the, the government is definitely stood
aside as corporations basically dictate policy.
Yeah. Fair enough. All
right. Thank you for the phone call, Dave.
Yep. Great to hear from you. Appreciate it.